ça y est l'été a bien commencé les
barbecues et les dîners au soleil aussi
mais lorsque le thermomètre augmente les
besoins de fraîcheur aussi au marché de
versailles les commerçants le savent
bien les demandes changeantes au fil des
saisons quand il fait vraiment très
chaud les gens ont envie de se
désaltérer et ont soif on va dire de
deux fruits frais ça va être des frais
rouge du melon de la pastèque mes pommes
les poires les pamplemousses
là on est sur des produits qui sont
vendus en petites quantités quelques
mètres plus loin même constat
actuellement ce qui marche le mieux ce
que le client achète le plus sur les
tomates anciennes donc là vous avez ce
que vous voyez là c'est de la mort de
crimée et vous en avez d'autres aussi
qui sont les coeurs de boeuf ou tomate
ananas donc ça c'est vraiment le produit
phare qui se vend le plus après en terme
de fruits on a tout ce qui est pêches
nectarines pêche blanche pedn les pommes
de terre ou les bons pour faire des
salades mais les gens conclut pure et
les gens font les gens comprennent
vraiment des produits frais qui demande
beaucoup de travail et qu'on peut mettre
en salade dans le jardin avec le
barbecue melons tomates pastèque ou bien
pêche ici ses fruits et légumes estivaux
représente plus de 70% des produits
achetés désaltérant frais et plus
faciles à cuisiner ils font l'unanimité
des clients du melon des vastech des
herbes des salades et tomates des
légumes on a envie de manger léger frais
des choses qui sont sont agréables en
tout cas ils n'ont pas besoin d'éviter
qu'ils sont qui ont du goût les gens ils
achètent à l'instinct s'il fait chaud et
vous vous achetez des produits qui vont
manger par rapport au temps si quelqu'un
arrive équipe le par exemple elle sera
moins tenté pour acheter du melon même
s'il fait beau le lendemain par contre
il fait 35 ou 40 devraient elles vont
acheter du melon de la pastèque même si
le lendemain il pleut alors que ce soit
smoothie gaspacho ou encore salade ses
fruits et légumes aux tons colorés
continueront de remplir nos assiettes au
moins jusqu'à septembre